everybody welcome back to park attacks
today it's time for the worst Park exact
scenario but it's terrible on purpose
I should add its disaster peaks and the
scenario description states that it's a
disaster of an amusement park and
maintained unclean and unsafe that said
the area is too good to pass up and the
existing rides aren't bad once fixed
pull this park out of the gutter and
turn it into a gem and then there's a
lot of things that I need to fix an
overall park rating of 75 percent
cleanliness rating of 80 percent 750
guests in the park which is quite a few
and no loan debts I don't know if the
park slides out with loan debts but
we'll see how that goes anyway so let's
just get started now introduce this
scenario very quickly this is one of the
scenarios which I made and be very
upfront about it it's directly inspired
by ivory peaks no way ivory towers in
roller-coaster tycoon
which is likewise a park that is
terrible has lots of vandalism and
broken rides and things like that and
you basically have to fix up the park
and turn it into something better and I
thought that was a really interesting
concepts for a scenario it's also one of
my favourite scenarios at least in terms
of what you're given because it has
these two interesting dueling coasters
and in addition to that a swinging
suspended coaster very similar to the
one that's in ivory towers and whereas
ivory towers is called cloud 9 from what
I remember this one's called hurricane
so kind of a related name there but this
thing is supposed to be broken from the
beginning as far as I remember so yeah
there it goes
that thing doesn't work so we're gonna
have to fix that thing we don't even
have any staff so that's something I'm
gonna have to work on and if you check
out the paths you can see I'm actually
just gonna pause the game before things
become even worse you can see that there
is trash and vandalism absolutely
everywhere so altogether this park is
kind of a mess and we're somehow gonna
have to fix this thing just fix all of
the vandalism and litter mostly by
hiring a bunch of employees I suppose
fix hurricane
and yeah just kind of go from there I'm
actually wondering what our right
selection is that's not too bad actually
if floorless coaster is a decent thing
to start with not to mention that as
much as this park has its problems from
the get-go these two rides here do have
very good stats so we are gonna have to
check up these prices and these are
probably going to be our main sources of
revenue from the beginning onwards and a
good way to pay for the repairs that
we're gonna have to make so yeah let's
get started and see if I can turn this
park around yeah by the way so just a
quick disclaimer the silver end you just
heard on the intro was recorded a few
weeks ago and I don't know why he sounds
like he has a hangover
maybe I did honestly I can't even tell
you but my voice is definitely screwed
on that clip don't know what's up with
that anyway starting here I decided that
the theme that this scenario comes with
is absolute jank and I wanted to do
something about that so I'm kind of
starting all over like I am honestly
just gonna roast what I built here
before because it was it was not good it
didn't look very nice but then again I
do think that for the majority of these
scenarios I had the idea that everything
had to look quite simple like I really
wanted to keep the scenery quite toned
down so that anybody could jump into
these scenarios and
built them in whatever way they wanted
so they could either build on the
scenery that's already there or just
build a much more generic Park and focus
on gameplay instead and it wouldn't look
out of place so forgive my below what
you're expecting of me level of the
scenery on some of these scenarios
because for me at least the gameplay is
more important than what the scenarios
really looked like which to be fair it
does seem to be a more important thing
to some people like some people even
though they play the scenarios they're
really more all about the aesthetics and
especially even looking around the
scenarios that come with the game and
seeing what they look like which is also
fine you know everybody there each to
their own I guess
but I really wanted to like hit some
sort of middle ground with some of these
builds
so disaster Peaks was quite generic and
very simple in terms of scenery when you
first get it even though the the setting
of the map I would say is more unique
than just that and there are some
interesting and layouts of the coasters
but yeah I think the scenery is
definitely something where rather than
building my completely you know the new
own things in this scenario I want to
give the existing scenario kind of a
makeover give it some more theming and
see where we can go from there so my
idea was to defy this scenario into
three different lands I'd say even four
different ones because the entrance area
is also going to be its own area but
it's not really going to have a theme as
much as the three other ones so we have
this area with the two dueling coasters
Maelstrom and firestorm then we have the
area with the suspended coaster called
hurricane which is going to have its own
theme and finally I'm gonna have to
build one new area because I think you
know with all the work that goes into
fixing up the existing parts of this
scenario I'll be able to get a large
amount of customers into the park and
almost reach the goals of the scenario
but I really just have to build one new
area with more attractions to reach the
the actual objectives so that's going to
be my third area where I'm gonna have
some kind of other theme now I did want
to have a sort of common thing among all
of these themes so my idea was generally
to make them all based on harbour or
ports the themes in general anything
that's related to the sea and it's some
kind of port activity so my first theme
was going to be Viking sort of very
Norse Nordic Viking esque theme I'm not
even entirely sure what to call this but
if you're looking at the building that
I'm building right now you're probably
getting some of the vibes that I was
going for here maybe even a little bit
inspired by some of the stuff that you
see in Skyrim
or some of those other Elder Scrolls
games lots of woodwork lots of wooden
carving detailing which obviously I
can't really get into architects but I'm
using all of the small wooden piece
borders and pillar pieces to create
those sort of details so it's that kind
of vibe which I'm going for which to be
honest I was kind of fighting with the
scenery research team again because I
wanted to get the fantasy theme and I
wasn't really sure if the fantasy theme
was included in the research that you
get in this scenario but I wanted to try
it anyway so I researched for a bunch of
months after you know fixing up the park
and making sure that the vandalism and
trash all over the the pass was gone but
they just kept researching things that I
didn't want and I was getting kind of
annoyed because I had basically all of
the themes already available from the
get-go in the scenario you actually
start off with a lot of scenery so I
figured you know if fantasy was included
I would get it quite quickly but nope I
ended up getting race props and sci-fi
statues and pipes and all of this kind
of nonsense that I didn't need and I
eventually even you know gave up
researching the scenery at all because I
figured that the fantasy just wasn't
included in the scenario because I kept
getting everything but fantasy so I
stopped researching and just started
building which is why you can see me
building with the mostly the default
pieces here and using some of these
standard roofs to create this structure
but eventually at some point later in
this video
I do end up getting the fantasy theme as
soon as I start researching again which
of course you know that's bound to
happen when you're spending a lot of
time trying to get something you don't
get it and you give up you you know you
should have just gone for one more
attempt and then you would have gotten
it of course that's always the case so I
ended up you know sort of redoing this
building at some later stage to make the
roof a bit more interesting and detailed
but the general shape of the building
and the placement and the colors and all
of that are going to remain intact and
this is really going to be the main
weenie and point of reference for this
area I would say everything else that
comes around
it because I will include a bunch of
other buildings and a flat ride are
really just you know some some added
spice to this area and kind of keeping
in mind that the station of these
coasters should be the centerpiece of
this whole themed land which I think it
also kind of makes sense because these
coasters are also the star attraction I
always just like to go for that kind of
Disney approach where every themed area
has its own main attraction that is
usually connected to the largest
building that draws people into the area
and gives it its its own kind of
identity because it just kind of works
in real life theme park design is really
effective but in park text it also means
that you can just have these few
attractions that you focus on that bring
in most of the money and then create a
little area around it with some theme
rides and shops and things like that
to you know fix up the gameplay aspects
of this this whole theme park
management's the thing as well so that's
pretty great I mean if you look at it in
real life I think some pretty obvious
examples of that would be for instance
Space Mountain or Big Thunder what's it
called again Big Thunder Mountain
Railroad I forgot the exact name but you
know that that might rain in this knee
that's at all the parks because these
are the biggest attractions that you can
usually see them from all around the
park they are the main attractions in
their respective themed lands but those
themed areas then you know once you're
brought in by that main attraction then
you always have a bunch of things to do
around it and other things to spend your
money on as well so honestly I think
following that approach of Disney parks
is quite effective in Project X for
making parks that manage to make money
and look pretty decent as well it also
kind of helps because once you get that
sort of main attraction out of the way
then you establish a style for the rest
of the area to follow because I wasn't
really too sure how I was going to take
all this Nordic themed and park tech
that never tried anything similar and I
haven't seen many people do a theme like
this either so once I had the main
station building in place I kind of had
an idea of how things could look
what pieces to use so that made making
most of the other buildings a lot easier
as well so after I got the main station
in I built a small flat ride just a
wipeout which is not really the flat
right that I was hoping for I was
secretly hoping that this park would
start out with a pirate ship because
obviously that would be the most fitting
for the theme we don't have that though
and I guess the wipeout is the next best
thing because it's also kind of related
to a nautical theme in some way and
after that I'm just adding a food market
where we have some drinks and some
burgers and some toilets as well now
food and drinks I think are going to be
one of the main challenges of this park
because I already noticed that the park
is huge and people are gonna have to
walk a lot so they're gonna get quite
tired and if anybody gets too hungry or
thirsty at any point in the park and
there isn't you know a shop closeby and
especially if they're also already tired
they're just gonna get more and more
angry as they can't fulfill their needs
so where the park is huge as this one
that's going to be the main challenge I
think and that's definitely something
that made my rating quite low and make
people really unhappy for a while
contrary to the problem that I usually
have which is that I don't have enough
intense rides because this park
definitely has enough intense rides
already from the get-go with two pretty
good dueling coasters that both actually
bring in quite a lot of money as well
and also hurricane the suspended coaster
has pretty good stats I think really the
challenge here isn't so much to keep
people happy with the rides but rather
to look after all of their other needs
and sort of build some kind of
infrastructure around the existing rides
of the park that allows this to actually
function as a good park rather than just
a huge expansive park with a couple of
good rollercoasters but very terrible
otherwise which is kind of what this
scenario starts out with so moving down
here I'm just adding a small harbour
area because in the end the idea is that
every themed land is some kind of harbor
so I'm just adding a small pier here and
so that was it I was it was weird
how I try to ride the word here with the
word peer that should not be a thing
that's like some mmm stuff right there
anyway just this just a small harbor
area to get the idea of the theme across
even though it is going to be quite
simple and very small and not going to
you know look too much into it it's
something that I think helps sell this
themed area not to mention create a
transition into what are going to be the
other future themed lands of this of
this park because I do want to pay
attention also to highlight transition
between the different themes because
building different themed lands is
something that I also don't have much
experience with within architect
scenarios so if this goes well it's
something that I like to do in the
future as well but for now it's it's
kind of a test now I'm gonna have to
apologize here I lost a bunch of footage
because my hard drive was full so I'm
just gonna skip forward a little bit and
you'll see some of the stuff that I've
built in this real time section coming
up alright so here we go I managed to
turn the park around if somewhat I'd say
it actually ended up making quite a bit
of profits once I switched these
coasters to to Train ops now the moment
where this happened isn't really visible
anymore but I remember it was in March
year three ethic and it's the first time
I suddenly showed up to almost a
thousand a month operations made such a
big difference on this thing these two
coasters used to run just one train each
so I switched it to two trains because
there are block breaks in front of the
launch and also in front of the station
so it is made to run two trains each and
that almost doubled the income that I
was making of course it didn't continue
the whole time so especially when
there's a thunderstorm income goes down
quite a bit but altogether I think it's
a good case for why you really need to
make sure that your coaster is run as
efficiently as possible because the
layout isn't the only thing that's
really important your operations are
super important as well the only thing
is sometimes if if the staff in the
station is particularly slow for some
reason the coasters aren't in sync
anymore so now we have this situation
which is a bit annoying it's very sad to
not see them do all anymore and this is
probably
why I had them set to one train ops but
to be fair I am taking the Six Flags
approach I don't care about whatever the
guests are experiencing on these rides
and whether they're actually going to be
dueling I just want to focus on
operations and getting as many people
through these things as possible so yeah
that's how we're gonna do this other
than that here's just the overall
North's Norse Viking is kind of area not
exactly sure what to call it but I was
just inspired to create some sort of
fantasy Viking esque Harbor so this is
what it ended up being and honestly I
didn't really add too much I guess I
added the wipeout over here but other
than that I'm pretty much just leaving
this area as it is no new coasters or
anything like this and I am planning to
do the same with the area around
I believe this thing is called hurricane
yep
and I'm not entirely sure if this is the
theme that I will go for but I think I'm
probably going to go for some kind of
catfish Cove North American kind of
wooden harbor town maybe inspired by the
coast of Vermont or am I say they they
they don't have a coach do they even no
they don't a Maine or something like
that anywhere in the the northern parts
of North America could even be Canada
some kind of American in northern ish
architecture and then for the other side
because over here there's a big empty
plot of land where I'm currently not
allowing anybody to go but somehow these
people ended up here and I'm not
entirely sure how oh their security did
I did I mess this up Oh how did they end
up there okay whatever I'm gonna MIT I'm
gonna move these guys what I ended up
doing of course is closing of this
entire stretch of land which I think was
a pretty good decision oh there's
there's a there's a connection here okay
that's the mistake but yeah altogether
it works out really well because it kept
all of the guests in the area where
there are rides and stuff like this so
that I can make more money so I'm really
glad with how that turned out as well
and I'm also quite happy with how the
waterfront area
came out I might put a bit more scenery
around this section of the layout but
it's gonna be really difficult to do
that but I do like the interaction that
the waterfront has with the coasters
over here so I think these are just
things to take with me into the next
themed area I have to say I'm already
kind of excited about starting a new
themed area so far every scenario that
I've done I just decided to do
everything in one theme more or less and
I'm really starting to consider why I
didn't branch into different themes for
some of the larger parks because
especially for smaller scenarios I think
it makes it more sense to stay within
one theme but with how spread out this
scenario is and just how huge this map
is I think it's a it's a cool
opportunity to try some different themes
as well and all have them just related
to this big central harbour theme so
without further ado let's get back at
the building and see how it goes all
right so it's time to go to the themed
area of hurricane Orwell the area that
is currently unthink
where I want to come up with some kind
of way to make it a bit more interesting
now I will say that out of the different
themed lands of this park this one's
going to be the least detailed or the
least thoroughly themed if you will
because the theme is going to be quite
simple and generic I'm going for some
kind of coastal town in North America so
it's really going to feature a lot of
very generic basic architecture lots of
colored wood and kind of colonial
architecture so not all that interesting
but I think in the end it ends up
looking pretty cool and quite charming
and really manages to bring out the
focus on the suspended coaster and I
think it's it's also an interesting
theme to use for this thing because I
figured that this kind of coaster would
be too difficult to work into a heavily
themed land with lots of buildings
because this this this coaster needs
such a huge clearance between itself and
the environment that I really couldn't
put as many buildings around here as I
did with the Viking slash Nordic themed
area and definitely no
as much as I am going to with the third
themed area of this bike so yeah this is
going to be a bit more simple I'm just
gonna have the suspended coaster go
through some forests have it interacted
with the hills it's very much I think
like suspended coasters in real life
like ninja at Six Flags Magic Mountain
those for instance these coasters are
just so good at weaving their way
through natural environments making
their way on and off some hills flying
through the trees I think that's just
kind of what these coasters do best and
I feel like I would just make a mistake
to make it huge themed area around it
with lots of buildings and things like
that I think this one is just better
kept simple from my personal experience
Ninja is actually the only one that I've
ever been on
but eagles fortress is a coaster that I
wish I had been on it's a Neverland
Korea and it's arguably one of the best
coasters that was ever built it's hard
to say this because very few people
actually wrote that thing now of course
I guess millions of people wrote that
thing but mostly Koreans because it's
quite a difficult park to get to for
international people and especially
within the coaster enthusiasts
it was something that not a lot of
people had had been to and the coaster
also closed many years ago it wasn't
even open for that long I believe it was
because it was just so intense that the
coaster just took a massive strain on
the track and because arrow had already
gone out of business it's a difficult
and costly coaster to maintain so
Everland just decided to you know leave
it standing but not operating for a few
years and eventually removed it as well
which is a shame because it it's an
absolute like example of what you can do
with the suspended coasters if you make
them a little bit more intense than just
your average average family coaster
because that thing was swinging from
side to side in some absolutely insane
ways it's really cool I highly recommend
checking out a POV if you're interested
in roller coaster POVs because that
thing is just really cool I hope that
one day the suspended coaster kind of
makes its comeback and that we don't
just have these family suspended
swinging coasters anymore but really
some more intense ones as well because
the
the concept of it is super cool and it's
definitely one of the best coaster types
I think suited for having this kind of
terrain based interaction there are lots
of really interesting no-limits
creations with suspended coasters as
well that I'm a big fan of so yeah
basically I ended up going way too off
topic on that one but that was kind of
the spirit that I wanted to embody with
this coaster as well so I'm adding also
a lot of foliage compared to what was
already there because I really want to
have this very dense lush foliage around
the coaster that you really get the
sense that you're diving through the
trees and up and down this hill and
going over the paths just having all
this disinterest interesting interaction
especially with the railroad underneath
it as well I think just a general golden
rule is the more different things kind
of cross their paths that the cooler it
ends up looking and I think this is
something that worked in rollercoaster
tycoon and still is very true today in
parkzicht and in real life theme parks
as well like when different rides have
interaction with each other or with the
paths or with the natural environment
the more all of these kind of things
stack up on each other it's just so much
more interesting and dynamic than a
simple coaster placed on a flat plane of
a parking lot hmm Six Flags so yeah
that's that's what we're going for here
now the architecture is also very simple
I'm really just taking my inspiration
from the coastal towns in North America
maybe areas like Nova Scotia or Maine or
the west coast as well just these kind
of almost Scandinavian ish buildings but
then with a more American colonial
architecture kind of vibe to it lots of
colored wood and white trims and very
simple cheap architecture that should
work in these kinds of wet and cold
climates and of course I would say
actually the weenie of this area is
going to be the lighthouse given that
you know this is a ports themed Park I
wanted to have a lighthouse somewhere
and I think this theme deserves it the
most I'm not sure about what kind of
lighthouses the the Nordic Vikings had
and for the third theme I think a
lighthouse wouldn't be that interesting
so this is the theme where I'm putting
that one and I think that's also going
to make the scene at the lake really
interesting obviously we don't have a
first-person perspective in parka text
but having this kind of lighthouse
sitting at the lake I think will look
really interesting from the rest of the
park at least that is the kind of
fantasy that I'm coming up with in my
hand honestly I've had a bunch of
discussions recently about the art style
of park text and what I see in it
because it's it's interesting how
polarizing it is I suppose not
necessarily in a bad way I've just
noticed that there are lots of people
who really really dislike the the
general art style of parks text and
there are people who really really like
it there barely even seems to be a
middle ground and I think a lot of it
comes down to whether you're into this
kind of diorama the fantasy kind of
aspect of it because obviously in Park
texts nothing is as real as the things
that you build in games like planet
coaster or no limits but for me this is
this is kind of part of the charm it's
like you're building the general idea of
something and filling in the gaps in
your in your head with as if it's some
kind of fantasy almost in the same way
that I used to build Lego cities when I
was younger and I would just try to come
up with how things would really look in
my head and for me that just really
works I love that suspense of disbelief
and building something very quickly and
very basically and coming up with a kind
of lore for it in my head and an idea
because also no matter what you build in
a theme park game I think your
imagination is just always cooler and
some of the some of the aspects of that
imagination I think are most intact in
park effects and I mean that but also I
just liked the the nostalgic similarity
to the art style of rollercoaster tycoon
games now very quickly to wrap up this
area I added a train station with a very
iconic American kind of colonial style
spire next to it
I had to add some kind of spire to this
area and that basically finishes this
general area there are a couple of
little sheds alongside the water as well
where I imagine boats could be
maintained or built or things like this
but other than that it's really just
forests all the way down so moving from
that into what is not really the third
area but I'm just gonna count this as
the entrance area because before I went
into working on the the third proper
themed land I wanted to fix up the
entrance because throughout the whole
video you haven't seen this I think but
I just blocked a bunch of random stuff
at the entrance to keep the guests happy
like shops and toilets but it looked
horrible and I wanted to get rid of that
before I finished up the scenario so I'm
adding a proper themed area kind of here
the idea behind this and here we go with
the lore of this park is that this park
is some kind of all estate from some
kind of royal family or whatever so this
is going to be where the the real palace
is and it's not going to be really big
but it is going to set this theme kind
of in a similar way I would say to zoos
like schönbrunn palace in Vienna or
maybe even PI D dizer in Belgium where
you come into an entrance area and you
can see that there's older architecture
that predates the the modern Park and it
kind of just creates this this really
interesting vibe of we're going into the
place with history and even though it
currently has the this theme park layer
to it it's it's older than that as well
so there's going to be a mention here
with a symmetrical and of European
garden in front of it and like I said
it's not going to be too big I don't
want to go all out on this one maybe
it's even just an old summer park of
some kind of old royalty
whatever the exact backstory is it gives
off the idea that this this Park is
something that used to have a different
kind of very high function
was eventually taken over a few decades
ago by this this theme park sort of
function which is I don't know I just
like that thing I think I do it too much
I end up doing it right now in Kamali's
Zoo as well and fun facts I was planning
my own zoo and planet zoo before I
realized that I didn't really have
enough time to commit to that without
sacrificing time to my park attack
series and things like this so I didn't
end up doing it but I had the idea for a
quality for a planet to build as well
where I start creating this this giant
old 19th century refurbished castle and
builders who around that as well
I just love taking old places like this
and getting the idea that they've been
somehow retrofitted into an amusement
park so it's also interesting because I
usually build very simple more rustic
themes in Park text and I've never
really built these large-scale
symmetrical builds but just with this
small tiny symmetrical garden I kind of
enjoyed it and I think there's probably
some potential here I'm not sure if any
of the scenarios in the dlc are going to
work too well for that considering that
in the main game I think I only have
Robo Park and the final scenario to to
do so there's not a lot of space to
experiment with anymore but I think if I
get the opportunity I would love to
build some kind of classical themed Park
which follows more of a symmetrical
layout because I always used to think
that you know it would look really
boring and park text and not really as
interesting as messy more small scaled
themed areas are but at the end of the
day looking at this I think there is
definitely some potential to be had
there especially given that you can very
easily create classical buildings with
some of the sets that are already in the
game now this food corner here is also
super simple but just a really cool
showcase of the 3d sign which was added
I believe in the DLC patch which is just
super cool I really love that thing the
fact that you can actually create your
own 3d signs with water
for text it says it's something that I
always forget is in the game but
whenever I realize that it's in it I
just want to use it for everything so
from this point onward I'm gonna try not
to forget that that's in the game
anymore and make more use of it and some
of my scenario builds because it's
really cool and it just allows for so
much creativity I think I remember in
Sakura gardens actually used it to
create some fences which are off the
grid because of course fences in the
game you have to keep them on the grid
but sometimes if you're building
something of the grid you can use some
signs to create fences or some other
kinds of detail I mean the options are
limitless but the options are only
limited by whatever characters you can
come up with to put on the signs and the
size and color that you give them so
there are so many things that you can
play with there it's really cool now
moving into this next themed area this
is going to be interesting because it's
going to be a Dutch themed area I would
say generally because it's not
specifically Dutch I was more generally
inspired by Hanseatic architecture so it
could be somewhere in North Germany or
maybe even in Denmark anywhere along the
lines where the Hanseatic glue is active
I think Hunslet Park is a really really
good example of the kind of theme that
I'm gonna go for here just red brick
houses with stepped gables and things
like this I really love this kind of
architecture and of course it's
something that's really close to me
personally as well and I'm still
wondering why I didn't try this kind of
theme earlier in Park text it's very
easily doable and we have some steps
gable pieces in the game so it's it's a
theme that's just really fun to build
with and it's very possible also to
build in Park text because you know to
what extent a theme is doable in the
game is still something that I always
want to work out before I dive into it
because the pieces are limited of course
but this theme I think it's very doable
and it's lots of fun to do there's a lot
of stuff available in the game to work
with now for the main attraction of this
themed land I'm going with the floorless
coaster which is again
pretty thrilling coasters so we don't
really have anything for kids in the
park I would say that the suspended
coaster is a good family coaster because
it's not too intense it's very much like
ninja in Six Flags for instance a decent
slightly thrilling coaster but it
doesn't do anything too intense so with
this floorless coaster we do have
another high intensity ride to join the
maelstrom and firestorm so maybe it
isn't the best decision after all from a
park perspective I just really wanted to
build this thing because it's I think
the most fun coaster type to build that
I ended up getting in the research and I
say that I ended up getting in research
but to be honest you have this coaster
from the get-go in the scenario I think
and I just started researching to see
what else I could get and ended up
getting bobsled coaster and other stuff
that I wasn't really looking forward to
building so I'm building a floorless
coaster in the end and it's also just a
good one to rake in the money and guests
because I do need to finish the scenario
after all and I don't want to start
making or stop making a profit so for
that reason the Flores coaster is also
just great because it usually gets a
really high excitement rating and has a
very good capacity especially with how
pretty short this layout is and with the
block at the end of the right so that I
can run two trains this thing should be
able to make me a good deal of money as
well so once we start getting that money
I can pay off my loan start advertising
for the park and then hopefully if
everything goes according to plan I'll
be able to finish this scenario so as
you might see I'm really going for a lot
of interaction with the path here and
very wide paths alongside this kind of
lakeside Bulevar but between the coaster
and the path I do want to add some
buildings too so here on the corner is
going to be my first little test with
the color of the brick and testing some
of the roof pieces and the steps Gables
looking at that I figured that I could
run with it and just see where it ends
up so I already started out creating
some of the facades of the future
buildings to get an idea of the overall
layouts of this area this area kind of
has to Rainey's I guess and doesn't
really ask clearly establish one
identity because you will see in a
minute that the coaster station and the
train station are kind of going to clash
a bit and they're also a little bit
hidden between some of the facades here
but I'm not really too concerned about
that overall this is definitely an area
that feels much more coherent and whole
than the other 2 themed areas it's quite
small and it's all just one big
interconnected plaza so I think it works
the way that it will and I'm pretty
happy with how some of the detailing
came out as well so even though I wasn't
too sure about this
in the beginning it's definitely a theme
that has some potential and how I would
say that you could do so much more with
this theme then I ended up doing here
I'm a little bit sad with how limited I
am in what I'm doing because most of
these buildings are just simple two by
two buildings using the the in-game
cables it's really just kind of simple
and not too experimental I think
personally I did enjoy my Japanese build
of Sakura gardens for instance much more
because it it just uses the pieces of
the game more creatively and this theme
just it's literally just putting some
boxes of the already existing pieces in
the game so it's quite simple but it
just works too well as well so I don't
know even though it's not something
where I feel necessarily that proud of
it I think it's a thing that just works
out really well so that's mostly why I'm
surprised why I haven't tried it before
or why it doesn't seem to be you know
that much of a commonly tried thing in
the game in general because it's just
really fun now because I have a lot of
paths going around here I do want to
fill up all of the available space that
I have that isn't paths or a coaster
with buildings or foliage just do not
make it look like an empty sea of
concrete so you can see some trees in
between some of the planters there which
I think really helps bring this area
together and then behind these facades
I'm adding the the coaster station
building and you can probably notice
what I was talking about here earlier it
is a little bit here
and if you were looking for the lake you
would kind of see it you know in the
distance and behind some of the facades
that are at the waterfront but I think
it kind of works because it is also
placed at a higher elevation and it's
also just a taller building and I'm
gonna start adding a dome to the top of
this as well so once that's all in place
I think it at least does a decent job at
being a weenie even though it doesn't
have the the clear sight lines that some
weenie should have I think the fact that
it blends into the rest of the area a
little bit more is maybe also somewhat
of an advantage as well I also very
accidentally created some clock gables
on the sides here I wasn't really
intending on doing that I was just
struggling because this station is three
blocks wide which is always a bit
annoying because that means that you
have to fill in the middle with some
kind of different roof piece and also
the gabled roof or now the gabled wall
pieces so that the stepped gable pieces
they don't have a middle piece like you
have one for the left and one for the
right wall but you don't have this piece
that you would need in the middle so I
was kind of annoyed at that at first but
looking at it in hindsight it actually
works out a lot better as this kind of
clock gable where you see the middle
section comes out higher than the sides
which is maybe usually a bit weird but
for this this Dutch kind of theme I
think it works perfectly and it's kind
of gable that you see very often if you
go to cities like Amsterdam for instance
so even though I kind of did it
accidentally once it was in place I
realized that it really helped sell the
idea of a Hanseatic slash Dutch kind of
architecture so I'm keeping it there and
of course also there is the dome on the
middle of the building which almost kind
of makes it look like some kind of
chapel I'm not entirely sure what kind
of function this building would have
within the context of this theme but I
think despite you know how hidden it is
and how the location and placement of it
isn't quite what I was looking for it
still manages to be a decent we need to
the area and something that clearly the
markets that this is the station
building and this is where you want to
go if you want to write this coaster
that is going around this entire themed
area so for the train station I'm
keeping this one a lot more simple it is
basically this this two-by-two building
that you see at the waterfronts but then
stretch to fit the entire footprint of
the station building so a large
horizontal kind of section with two
facades jutting out at the front I could
have also turned this into more of a
station like building and AD aspire to
it as some kind of tower or dome I was
very kind of yeah I was I was almost
doing this but then I realized that now
if I did this then the entire building
would just end up taking away some of
the attention from the coaster station
building and they would kind of start
fighting for attention within this theme
and I figured it would make more sense
to just make this building a bit more
subtle and give it some facades at the
fronts that create more of a harbor city
vibe rather than just a bunch of fancy
buildings in a forest vibe I don't know
if that makes sense
but I figured it was better for the
themed area as a whole to sacrifice this
train station and not make it too fancy
or detailed and just make it look much
more like some of the other smaller
buildings in this area and after that's
done it's pretty much most of this area
in place the only other thing that still
left to do is finishing up the
waterfront and making this look a bit
more like an actual Harbor City so just
like the Viking area I ended up adding a
small wooden pier and also a teacups
ride which for a second I was
considering whether I could make this
look like Delft Slough which is a Dutch
kind of pottery but I think it would
just be really difficult to get those
colors in so I ended up going for a much
more
generic color scheme on the teacups here
but all things considered I think it
fits into the theme especially
considering that this this theme plant
is very inspired by Dutch architecture
and the flower is a big part of Dutch
culture or at least heritage I would say
so I am happy with it here the only
struggle that I still had was what to do
with the roof of this thing obviously as
you all know if I place a flat ride I
can't help but add a roof to it and
while I am trying to get out of that
habit because sometimes it's not the
best thing to do for teacups
you know these this is a classic the
flat ride which has to have a roof on
top of it so I made this roof quite
simple just added some fantasy roofs in
the middle and I'm not sure if I'm a
huge fan of this shape I might come back
to that later but I really just don't
have any better ideas this teacups roof
I guess just doesn't really need to look
nice on its own it's just kind of here
to provide a flat ride and to close off
this part of the the general area to
just have a big building here it feels
right for the layouts of this area is
what I'm trying to say but I'm not sure
about the actual design of the roof
itself but I'll probably keep it this
way because I can't really come up with
anything that's much better
and even if I do know some roof shapes
that I like more than this one I do
still want to try and come up with a new
roof design for every flat right roof
that I make so I'm trying to avoid
repetition as much as I can and this is
probably also in vain like at some point
I'm just gonna forget what some of the
roofs that I've already built looked
like but for the time being I really
want to keep it up so this is what it is
now finally as what is probably going to
be the last flat ride in this entire
Park I'm adding one of these things I
totally forgot the name of it so let's
just call it loop-de-loop swinging ship
or whatever it's really intense it's
probably one of the harshest flat riser
you can add into the game but some of
the other flat rights in this park are
already just the teacups and the
wipeouts which are not that intense
so I think adding an intense flat ride
makes sense thinking of it now this park
really really lacks some of the basic
simple flat rights like a carousel or a
slide or a chair swing I really don't
have any of that stuff maybe I'm
actually gonna go back into this thing
and add something like that because it
does feel like a flat right like that is
missing in this this Pike but for now I
think this this was a decent right to
add to round up this area so that is
basically it's for the Hanseatic area
just adding a little bit of scenery
before I move into the final parts of
this time-lapse which if I skip forward
to that you could see is gonna be
another train station because it's just
it's just time to end another train
station I started out this park with
trees three-straight oh my god I started
out this park with three train stations
of course because that's what you get
when you open this scenario and I
quickly removed two of them because they
were both in a part of the park and then
I closed off for visitors because I
didn't want the people to walk over
there and started getting too tired so
I'm slowly opening up those train
stations again and I want to build some
kind of unique design for every part but
for this area I wasn't really sure what
to do I wanted the train station to fit
in with the entrance building and the
general very generic look of this part
of the park but then building just a
generic train station is kind of boring
so I started going back into my head and
reasoning you know at what point in time
with the park entrance have been built
and what kind of architecture could fit
with that so I was thinking that perhaps
this park started you know being open to
visitors to some extent in the early
20th century and at that time there was
still a lot of modern and Art Deco
architecture going around and there was
a lot of attention in this field so I
figured if there's any kind of modern
architecture that I like that works with
train stations it's probably Art Deco so
this thing is gonna have a very simple
stripped-down modern art deco look to it
I'm really not going to look too much
into it it's not going to be all that
detailed but when it comes to the over
atmosphere I'm trying to take in some of
that art deco so basically the roof is
very simple and just based on what the
entrance building is like to make that
fit in as much as possible but I'm
adding some classical details here and
there as you would see with our Deco
buildings like pillars and the the spire
is really where this mainly comes out
and it's just so simple it's so simple
it's almost stupid it's just a bunch of
cubes stacked on top of each other with
some pillars here and therefore that
vertical detailing and it just works so
well like this instantly made me think
you know I didn't spend much time on
this train station and it's really
simple but Art Deco is a theme that is
very doable in parka text and with all
of the little cube pieces that are off
the grid you can really do a lot of
interesting detailing and composition
when it comes to Art Deco
so again this is maybe one of those
things that I might try at a later stage
in time I'm just really happy that I
decided to try different themes on the
same map here because all of this
experimentation even if it isn't you
know as good as some of my other builds
I think it just shows how much you can
still do with the game and how versatile
these pieces are because everything is
very simple that said that's the end of
this time-lapse so I'm gonna go off
screen and finish a bunch of stuff and
then I'll show you the park in its full
glory all right well we are here it's
just a question of whether or not I'm
gonna need to hold the goals for a few
months and there we go and I said I
would probably need to hold them for a
few months but it looks like it's only
three weeks so that'll be a bit more
doable I ended up having to add this to
be on at the entrance area very quickly
because I wasn't quite reaching the 750
required guests in the park for this
scenario and I'm not really happy with
it I probably should have put somewhere
time into it because it's not really the
best placement but in my defense I
really sort of filled up every space on
the map that I figured could be
conceivably filled up there's obviously
still a lot of space left but some of
that space is a bit more difficult to
get to and we just look a bit strange I
was looking into this area specifically
because I thought a small flat ride can
actually fit in this first helix of
hurricane and work out quite well but no
that's not gonna happen because it's
just that compact and I don't really
have any large flat rights available so
let me just start doing a tour because
I'm gonna assume that I'm gonna reach
the objectives by the end of these three
weeks so now I guess we've all seen the
Viking area enough but I'm just really
happy with how these roofs came out the
fantasy roof is just one of my favourite
pieces in the game just the shape and
detail of it is so good for different
themes and I'm really glad I ended up
you know pushing through and trying to
get that fantasy roof in the end because
it really pays off I think and even here
on the waterfront which isn't quite as
detailed or ridiculously as Seend
I still like some of the combinations of
the colors even though everything's
quite simple and I'm a bit disappointed
in myself that I didn't experiment a
little bit more with the pieces I think
altogether it paints an interesting
picture and the themed area is quite
coherent as a whole and then moving into
of course what I guess I should probably
call Hurricane Harbor that just sounds
like the perfect name for this little
themed area not too much to see but
we've got the suspended coaster going
around which is pretty cool and then of
course if we come back to the entrance
area here we have the the big sort of
landlord house here with the food corner
all very simple but I think it works all
rights to establish the mood of the park
as a whole and then moving into this
area a flat ride and the very simple Art
Deco station and god I know this thing
is just super simple and very basic and
nothing that I'm particularly inspired
by but I
to have this idea for our Deco
architecture and I really want to try it
in pocket it's a bit more one-day and
really see what you can do with some of
those basic pieces because that stuff is
just awesome and I'm gonna try to keep
in mind when I'm actually gonna finish
the scenario so looks like we'll just
have a minute or so more and then of
course we have the NZ attic town over
here for a really long time I wasn't
really sure what to do with this corner
because I also didn't want to block it
off completely because I wanted the the
view of the lakeside to be maintained
here and also to leave this entire area
visible from the other side of the lake
as well so I ended up just putting a
very simple seating area here with the
tree not super happy with it but I think
at least it doesn't disturb the the
layouts and the flow of the general
themed area that's already established
I'm actually gonna do a quick POV of
this coaster because I haven't yet and I
know I'm definitely thinking I have some
comments about if I don't do it I think
it's not really the best layouts that
I've ever made but it works in the
context of this themed area and I think
it has some really cool interaction with
the paths and the scenery as well so
that's nice
by the way the stats of this thing are
really good we've got an extreme
excitement rating and then a very medium
intensity rating and I can only guess
that that is because of the interaction
that it has with the train for instance
or the paths or some of the scenery just
the amount of scenery around it in
general either way this is a right that
works wonders when it comes to income as
you can see the last few months it's
been earning about a thousand a month
pretty steadily now I changed the pre
drop shaping because that was a bit
strange I'm still not super happy with
it but I think it works alright the way
that is right now you might notice by
the way that it is a tiny bit similar I
would say to day moanin in Tivoli
Gardens definitely a very different
layout but overall it has a similar set
of elements and even a kind of similar
flow to it even if it is a lot less
compact
then the moaning is for the longest time
by the way I was also planning to have
some kind of transfer track shed over
here but I'll be completely honest this
themed area feels more or less complete
just like that and I was too lazy to
build a boring shed over here because
it's just not something that I think I
could realistically experiment with a
lot and it would just be something I
wasn't looking forward to doing look the
scenario is already quite large and I've
spent a lot of time recording this I
haven't even featured all of my stuff
that I've worked on in this time-lapse
so it's been a while and I really can't
wait to move on to the next scenario so
with that said let's leave disaster
Peaks behind I think at least I've been
able to turn this back around and not
have it be a disaster anymore and in
fact I'm just really happy with the idea
to completely rethink the park and turn
it into something very different than
when it used to be with a bunch of
different themed lands like this so with
that said I'm pretty sure this is going
to be the trophy of the scenario as I'm
going to go back to the campaign menu at
least actually yeah now I'm entirely
sure because I had to make that building
specifically for this function so yeah
there you go
we have that little house in the middle
of the lake which is now blocked down
into the lake here and after that I
think oh yeah right there's still one
more scenario over here that I forgot
about which is sheer cliffs that's gonna
be interesting actually I'm not sure if
I'm gonna want to tackle Robo Park first
or sheer cliffs I think both of these
parks could be really interesting I know
I already always say this that I don't
really know which one I'm gonna do in
the next episode but sometimes there are
just these bikes that I really want to
get to but with these two I don't know
I'm not even sure if any of them is
easier I think Robo Park is probably a
bit easier given that actually I'm not
gonna spoil anything you guys are gonna
see that in the next episode I should
just stop talking and leave you to it so
I'm gonna see myself out here but I hope
you guys enjoyed this video
and I hope to see you in the next
episode bye everybody